[Music]
[Applause]
uh Tom W Mark Silverman host of uh WD
and Sylvie ESPN 1000 in Chicago they do
afternoon drive there you guys have been
doing this a long time Sylvia let me
start with you uh the level of
desperation in Chicago with the Bears is
what is a 100 on a scale of 1 to 10 um
Dan we've been through this lot you said
we've been doing this for a long time
the Bears have been doing this for a
long time it's rinse and repeat I call
it the circle of suck um Paulie knows it
well um we just went through a hiring
process a year and a half ago that got
Ryan poles and Matt eberl here they
didn't have to change the name plates
Matt and and Ryan uh were the previous
guys and they hired a Matt and Ryan and
um nothing has changed maybe it's gotten
worse we still don't know about Ryan
poles the jury is still out but Matt
Eber flu has to go I don't know what it
will do by firing him if they get
embarrassed tonight but he's got to go
at the end of the year and um especially
if you you end up drafting another
quarterback so yeah the it's at a 100
right now Dan you see Dan you see what I
deal with you ask him a simple question
that probably could have taken 10
seconds to answer and he sucks all the
oxygen out of the room it's like an 8020
you know you know verbal split on our
show for four hours well that is the
circle of suck it's sucking the air out
of of the room there what do you see on
the field with the Bears Tom uh I see a
team that can't stop anybody defensively
there's no creativity like you know I
I'm more concerned with their defense
right now than I am their offense and I
have some serious concerns about their
offense but you've got got a
defensive-minded head coach who plays
this cover two which you can still
succeed in this league with a cover two
but you got to be able to pressure the
quarterback with your front four and you
drop your seven in coverage they can't
pressure anybody and then they aren't
really aggressive or creative trying to
get quarterbacks off their spots so I I
think defensively they're in trouble and
offensively they just have not learned
how to win and I thought that was on
full display in the fourth quarter
against the Broncos I'll ask both of you
guys do you want Bears to win
tonight I do not no I do yeah
listen look look this can you admit
though publicly Tom that you like you
you're rooting for the Bears with a a
brighter future down the road here and
Caleb Williams and maybe Marvin Harrison
and a new head coach so could you say it
publicly being a former bear working in
Chicago no I can't uh um my fingers are
crossed my toes are crossed no here
listen I want them to win if in fact
this is the first of 12 in a row or this
is they're going to go 10 out of 11 if
they can find their way to a successful
season and get to the postseason then
that means a lot of stuff went right
maybe the quarterback you know built on
the three quarters he had against the
Broncos I don't think that's going to
happen so you know the realest In Me Is
is one that thinks that major change is
on its way and that may include having a
couple of the top three or four picks in
the draft next year what about you it's
too early it's it's too early to start
rooting for tank jobs I mean we're week
five like I'm I'm four rooting for
losing with four weeks left okay there
are too many players that need to be
developed and and Justin Fields you can
still Salvage and don't get me wrong if
you get get the number one pick whether
it's your pick or car they have
Carolina's pick so if you get the number
one pick I think Caleb Williams is too
generational of a talent to to skip him
even if Justin Fields shows progress you
must draft but you just you're gonna
drive yourself crazy if you start
rooting for your favorite team to lose
in week five but if you go seven and 10
are you bringing Justin Fields Back not
if you
have well if you have if if you have the
Carolina Pick you can always draft a
quarterback there you could you could
keep Justin for another year you have
him under contract for two years and sit
the rookie quarterback whoever it is or
you could trade Justin if he UPS his his
value sorry Wadd no no no I look um
seven and 10 doesn't necessarily mean
that the quarterback is coming back I I
think that there's a long way to go to
come to that Final Destination but um I
I don't think that you can just sit here
today before they kick the ball off
tonight and say that a specific record
would ultimately lead to the conclusion
that he is your answer maybe they win
these games in a fashion in which the
quarterback doesn't play a significant
role or in a manner in which you think
that he is your answer so I again I'm
with Sylvia in terms of it's it's way
too early to start cheering against your
team and and I'm a patient man
uh as I've gotten older I've gotten more
patient I'd like to see this whole
season play out because at the end of
the year you have to be 100% comfortable
and com uh confident and comfortable or
you could combine those words and you
have to know whether he is your guy or
he's not your guy with no gray area well
you know Chicago this this the sport
World in Chicago is similar to New York
where the Jets and Giants aren't good
the Yankees and Mets didn't make the
postseason uh you've got the Cubs uh
they bowed out
uh the socks aren't good the Bulls are
then you got the Bears I mean how's
morale there's no there's no morale Dan
there's no morale the white socks lost
101 games and they're bringing back
their manager the Cubs choked away a
four game lead in the wild card in the
last three weeks of the season and the
bears were supposed to build a bridge
into being this year's lions and then to
take off and they're 0 and four and
they're going to maybe fire everybody
again and and draft the next great
quarterback so morale has has left can
you say Tom that the 85 Bears were bad
for the city because the shadow is still
there it's still long and you're not
going to get close to that uh anytime
soon no you should never suggest suest
that something that was that magnificent
was bad it's not their fault that we
have wandered in the football desert
ever since that I mean I'm not gonna
blame Steve McMichael and Richard D Dan
Hampton and and Walter pton and Jay
hilgenberg and the list goes on and on
it's not their fault that we haven't
been able to find the promised land so
uh no I I I I think that you we still
celebrate them you know that yeah oh
yeah some people get a out of that oh
yeah but they're an alltime great so
they should be celebrated but we should
continue to put the pressure on the
organization to get us back to some
sense of success it's great to talk to
you I'll talk to you guys again uh right
before the NFL Draft when you have the
first and second pick we'll talk then
see you D lose our numbers thank you
guys Tom WD Mark Silverman part of w
Wadd and S ESPN 1000 been there a long
time
2 to 6 local time afternoon drive if
they like to call that